keep singing jets jets jets
speaking of my new york jets hello
everybody this is this is
my favorite show coffee and commerce
with uh the actual star
zubin uh who is the president of vayner
commerce we also have
literally i mean i i i don't know i
didn't talk to sabine but
deep down i just know him well enough
that he's probably like
freaking you know having a little fanboy
moment mark lori is one of the great
e-commerce executives of our generation
which means of all time since
it hasn't been around too long and
unlike the majority of my new york jets
mark lori will be going to the
e-commerce hall of fame
so hello everybody i see you all drew
baker christine leon
uh uh phil d good to see you nick b36 i
see the comments coming through all the
live streams at this point
uh much like i think you've been seeing
from uh coffee and commerce this is
becoming more and more zoobeen show i
kind of do a little kick off
the last week i lost my mind and just
talked the whole time to being so
impossible
i was hoping you did it today but it's
up to you i honestly
no i want you i want you to do your
thing i want to get it honestly with
mark i want to get a lot out of him
and i have a hard stop in 20 minutes
anyway so i'm sure you'll have some time
to jam
but uh mark is here i'll let him
introduce himself and give you some
context
uh and then we will get into some
questions
sounds good gary great to be here thanks
for having me
what have i thanks for have being with
us uh
where yeah i mean i'm so used to being a
guest thanks for having me
um mark why don't you get you know a lot
of people in my universe now because you
were on the podcast
you were on marketing for the now now
you're here have started to get to know
you but i'm sure there's tons of others
uh that are maybe meeting you for the
very first time
definitely not if they're in e-commerce
land but why don't you give a little
three-minute bio on who you are
sure sure i i started my career in
banking for about six years
got the bug to be an entrepreneur was
always an entrepreneur as a kid growing
up wanting to be an entrepreneur
but found myself in banking and then one
day just walk to my boss's office quit
become an entrepreneur and then i did
started four companies
and sold started and sold four companies
the last two
diapers.com to amazon and then jet.com
to walmart
and four years ago after the jet sale i
became the president and ceo of walmart
e-commerce been there for the last four
years
i love it and so when when did
mark's career or companies first hit
your radar
in and around 2005 2006 at diapers.com
i think part of it for for me having
been in the space was like
we're talking to brands trying to get
them to grow and trying to get them to
do things and everybody's talking about
uh well you can't do commoditized
products you can compete with amazon
you're gonna do this you're gonna do
that and
outcomes diapers.com selling something
that
you wouldn't expect and then you know
it's interesting to have
seen it from the vantage point of a
consumer and the growth from that
standpoint
and then to hear mark um and i'd love
for him to share with our audience as
well
kind of what he went through the
challenges he had and even being able to
get
product and then understanding from the
beginning
i mean this is a spoiler i'm basically
just mentioning what i'm asking him but
um but understanding from the beginning
that the diapers were almost a lost
leader
and i think that from a business
standpoint from a fact of somebody
actually achieving
critical mass on.com to your point yeah
absolute fanboy so mark i'd love you to
just kind of
elaborate on what i was mentioning right
there for the audience i mean that
that's exactly right the big vision was
you know let's get moms and dads with
newborn babies when they're first
starting their families let's get them
hooked in and then let's sell them
everything they need now
and anything they'll ever need in their
future um and in order to do that
um we felt diapers was it was a great
product category to start in because
when you have new baby you need to use
diapers on a regular basis
they're bulky they're a pain in the butt
to go out to the store and get and buy
and bring home
and we thought if we could offer diapers
delivered overnight
at the same prices that you'd find in
your store why wouldn't you do that and
if you started to do that every month
why wouldn't you buy your baby formula
and your wipes and your
accessories and bottles and if you did
that why wouldn't you buy your strollers
and car seats and everything for your
baby
if you did that why wouldn't you buy
your stuff for pets and stuff and so
that's kind of the way it
it it grew from the beginning but it
started with this idea that we would
sell
diapers basically at a loss and people
thought that was just crazy
you know and there was a reason why
nobody was selling diapers online
because they were bulky
heavy to ship and retailers didn't make
any money on them
but they didn't make any money because
they also drove traffic into the store
and so we thought okay great we know
we're going to take a loss
what we didn't know was that we couldn't
just buy diapers from the manufacturer
directly
even though we said yeah we'll buy them
in the truckload no
what we did we had no idea we never in
retail were like you can't just buy
diapers from the manufacturer if you're
a diaper
like company online no why
because we don't think the business
model makes any sense and we don't waste
our time
okay great so we'll buy our diapers then
at the wholesale clubs
you know at sam's club bj's in costco
which even increase the losses going
forward and also increase the complexity
having to go to the warehouse and buy
the stuff we had to do that for two
years we were doing we were cleaning out
multiple wholesale clubs like on a
weekly basis clearing them out
like and shipping the product to our
front lawn
boxing them and shipping them out it was
crazy and the only reason why we finally
were able
to buy from the manufacturer direct
after two years was they still said no
we don't want to sell you um but
uh we're getting calls from our
wholesale club very important clients
very important companies and they're
asking us to please sell you because
you're hurting
their business by clearing them out and
their customers come in they can't find
the diapers
um and you know the clubs used to help
us right we would buy the diapers they'd
help us load it on the truck
then they then they said you know we're
not going to load them on the truck
anymore
because you're you know we need
something for the for the customers and
we said oh
so you're worried about that are you so
we basically then
would not leave him any diapers clear
everything out and said listen just
please make a phone call
we can make this really easy just make a
phone call to procter and gamble let
them know that
you really want b and g to sell us and
that's what they did and then png sold
us
you know even though they didn't think
of us as you know
a real business or anything and then
fast forward 10 years later
brockton gamble was given a presentation
basically
new execs different team basically
saying that
uh you know they believe 70 of diapers
are going to be sold online in the next
five years
and it's going to go to 100. why would
anybody ever buy diapers in a store
that was basically the presentation um
so it took about 10 years to go from
this is doesn't make any sense to you
know
why would you buy it anywhere else which
which shows you that you gotta
sometimes just gotta take a little leap
of faith some risk
mark what is the biggest thing you know
before i get out of here a couple things
so let's go a little rapid fire with me
i'll go with the
kind of sizzle and i'll let zubin do
steak
when i get out of here sizzle time what
um
what are some of the you know and
actually the question i really want to
ask you feel free
you know i i have a lot of empathy when
one works in a bigger company and so
you're not in
full entrepreneur mode right now but
like direct consumer brands that have
stood out to you
in the last year any have you seen
anything or you so head down in your own
world
of some executions or anything that you
admire from afar or things that you
think are brewing that are cool
state of the union observation of things
that you think are being well done
in dot com in e-commerce specifically
i would say i haven't focused a lot more
on
not not only walmart but more like
innovative tech
thinking where the puck's going five and
ten years out so we haven't really been
focused so much on
sort of like the now on on ecom stuff
like
what what nerds you out the most without
disclosing maybe some top secret [ __ ]
on five or ten years from now what has
kind of got your spidey senses really
going
yeah there's a few different buckets i
mean you have the uh the one that's
probably
you know easiest to see happen which is
autonomous vehicles
and what that'll do to drive down last
mile delivery costs
you know same day delivery is going to
boom two hour delivery is going to boom
as a result as the costs come down
um drones we're already testing drone
delivery that in the next five years is
coming so that's kind of on the
on the delivery side of things knowing
you've seen around corners 15 years from
now because i'm five is just like people
lose the five year game all the time
15 years from now how many drones are
flying around or give me something
anecdotal like
everybody will buy something that's
delivered by a drone a week or a year
okay
you're probably looking at in 15 years
maybe 80 percent of households
get drone delivery i don't even think
it's going to take 15 i think inside of
10
you will see that inside of 10 you think
80 of homes will have at least one
package dropped in drones
or 50 of their packages are being done
by drones no i think there'll still be a
relatively low percentage
i think there'll be a battle you know
there'll be drones will be faster
and better for lighter uh smaller
packages
and as you start getting heavier
autonomous vehicles will be cheaper
fair enough nobody nobody wants [ __ ]
like
bowflex you know things like the drone
loses it and landing on heads and
people dying and [ __ ] yeah but i could
see by by
you know 15 years from now seeing maybe
15 to 20 of packages delivered by drone
which would be massive i mean that would
be
would be unbelievable how long
i'm going to say something garyvee
sitting in his house
uh 10 years from now on a day like this
it's the next coved i'm stuck inside i
want a root beer
i want a root beer and i want it now how
realistic
how well priced in what form because i'm
with you on two
under two hour and last mile and like in
my mind the debt
i play a lot with the concept of the
death of the convenience store
yeah like what's more convenient than
7-eleven uh hitting a button in your
house and not going to get chips and
cigarettes and
you know and a beer like what are you
seeing
yeah i think i think the idea of mobile
convenience stores
um you know for for the highest selling
you know
items with the most margin it's sort of
the convenience stuff that you talked
about
you know i already see a company's doing
that and it's an interesting space
like having these mobile uh autonomous
vehicles roaming around
and you basically either can can summon
it and call it or
you know when it passes by your house or
within a few minutes it pushes
notification and says
i'll be there in a couple of minutes do
you need anything uh from the
convenience store
uh or or on demand but i think if it's
autonomous and you're willing to sort of
go out on the street if you live in the
burbs to get it
then yeah it should be it should be
relatively cheap because you don't have
anybody driving the car
and uh yeah so so
i think we'll see that what will
retailers have to do
to still bring value to the chain in 20
years
in a world where delivery can be
commoditized by third-party services and
will will allow actual people that make
this stuff
compete with not having to give up the
margin
to stores or retailers yeah i think
i think it's it's going to be about
merchandising which is you know how
retail started
i think uh conversational commerce if
you want to fast forward
15 years as well i think most of
commerce will be done
for maybe 20 years it'll take some time
but most commerce will be done with
voice
and text um so the idea of being able to
converse with somebody
that knows you as well as your mom or
dad um
and has the product expertise or
knowledge of the most knowledgeable
person
on a showroom floor of a specialty
retailer and being able to converse
back and forth with a computer um and to
get to exactly the right product
um that you're looking for i think i
think we're so far from that today
you know the idea of putting something
in a search engine and getting thousands
of results
it doesn't know you you certainly can't
converse back and forth you have to dig
you have to filter
search read that's that's too much work
uh i don't i see that being the
battleground the other place
that i think uh could be a battleground
if you go fast forward 20 years when
when merchandising and and supply chain
become more commoditized
um is is really around proprietary
brands
so literally having really cool
brands and product that you can only
find at a particular retailer
and i'm not talking about private label
i'm talking about real brands
um that people will go out of their way
to buy and there's no substitute for
right now a lot of those brands are
separate they're not sold even
at you know mass merchant retailers but
as more and more pressure
uh occurs on those brands um they're
gonna need to team up with
you know one of the few players uh in
ecom that continue to gain share
so i i do see that happening
mark go ahead no question for you on uh
on that point so and we'll get to
entrepreneurship uh
in just a moment but we're talking about
um distribution centers right
and and the ability for to kind of
achieve omni channel and have
quick distribution leverage your
existing retail environment
uh for pickpack and shipping how
does a direct-to-consumer brand now and
how would you like to see it in the
future
how can they best kind of um
leverage omnichannel if they don't have
a physical footprint themselves
if they don't have a physical footprint
so d to c no physical footprint what
should they do
correct yeah it depends on i think
whether it's a premium
perceived as a premium brand or not if
it's more of a mass
more commoditized than getting a
physical brainward presence
in mortar retail you know like a walmart
yeah makes sense
um if it's more premium and it doesn't
make sense or you want to be on the
shelf of a mass merchant
um then you know these uh you know
pop-up shops
i think if you look at uh you know these
small you know uh
uh inventory list stores where you go in
and
and you basically can see the the the
merchandise
try it on even and then just get it
delivered you know same day or
or next day to your house so you don't
have to manage as big of a store
footprint
and shorter term leases so you can come
in use it as a marketing
build up your audience and then shut it
down and move it somewhere else so
i see it more as marketing um to really
drive
awareness but uh and get your sizing and
that sort of stuff but
i don't know about you know the
old-school sort of like big
footprint lots of locations long-term
leases
i'm not sure that's best mark what uh
what's your hot take on what's going to
happen to all these
b and c and d malls do you think will
you think there's any conversation
i mean there's definitely retail
conversation for us just
again smart guys point of view with a
lot of context a lot of conversation
you know any any thoughts i i think
i think that it's a downward trend i
think you'll see
ups and downs um but i think the
long-term trend is down i
i i think experiential uh
you know moving in to be more
experiential is is the best shot
but i think with vr you know in the not
too distant future
you're going to have amazing uh you know
experiences that make you feel like
you're in the most amazing
you know place to to experience stuff
you know even being able to go
to foreign destinations and things and
look at stuff and
i i uh yeah i just don't i don't see how
the combination of
vr coming on one side at you and uh
you know the conveniences of of product
you know being able to be shipped
to your door same day vr right like
i think vr i warned a lot of my vc
friends
six years ago five years ago on vr they
all got hot oculus
because of facebook and i was like you
know because i'm
and this is something i think you've
been great at as well i'm
consumer-centric
i'm not looking to go to stanford or sit
in a board room
or like i'm in the trenches in the dirt
i mean
no human is using vr like none
zero like like when i think about the
amount of hours spent on an iphone
by one person in a day come versus
the field the vr field let's just use
america 300 million americans
in hours on vr outside of b2b
conferences showing you what's going to
happen one day
to me that is like that's like a real
game right
so on that front what do you think is
happening
on that like like when i see zero
activity
i feel like it's further away than
people think
i think you're totally right gary i
think it is further away
it's going to happen one day but one day
could be could be a long time it could
be you know 15 or 20 years before it
really starts to become
you know it has to get the the oculus
the 3d goggles have to get a lot smaller
which means you need a lot more power
you need not just 5g
67g you know you're going to need you
know it needs to be much faster
where you know it's really interesting
to people and then you have to start
building all the content
and it'll take time to start building
content and you've got the chicken and
egg problem nobody wants to build the
content or convert the content right
yeah
yeah so it's funny i said like four
years ago and i really thought this
through and i'm um
you know again i respect your opinions a
lot so i
i appreciate the affirmation i actually
at the time said it will never be a
goggle game it will be a contact lens
game
because my intuition was it's going to
take so long for this to happen
by the time it gets around to it they're
going to be able to get this down to the
contact level
and you know like that that's my
intuition that like yeah it's play out
much longer than we think
and it and it might get to a level where
it's tiny
yeah i think that ultimately what we're
kind of evolving into is more ar right
the moment that vr had is actually
happening with
ar but but it would be a big device but
it is it
like because there's a lot of ar work
but again i mean i'll tell you the place
where thank god i wasn't on a hot
take of thank god i wasn't in a place
where i was making 8 000 pieces of
content a day
once pokemon go happened that gave me
the trigger of like
oh ar is here there are tens of millions
of americans
in [ __ ] pulling over on the highways
and going into [ __ ]
you know woods with unlimited ticks just
to pick up a [ __ ] pikachu that they
heard
might be there so i was like oh [ __ ]
like ar is here and i already dreamed
marvel
and disney and every ip you could
imagine following suit
i thought of a million other things and
if you told me
that we would be here six years later
still talking about pokemon go and
there's
no other scaled execution in in ar
besides pokemon go a cultural thought i
would have lost that
and i'm good at this [ __ ] i would have
lost my bad my question to
the two of you is why has that happened
do you does either one of you have a son
i think the energy shifted to
back to what you mentioned in terms of
consumerism and the fact that
the application that works really well
for that right now is you go to any
furniture store
online that knows what they're doing
like our client apartment 2b and you can
actually see the product
in your home right that's
real world application conversion rates
are much higher when somebody interacts
with
a piece of furniture those are niche and
i know there's those things
i agree i agree gary there's like a
tipping point there needs to be
enough of a reason to wear the glasses a
good portion of the day like you carry
your phone with you everywhere you kind
of
you kind of need to because you're not
going to just say oh wait
uh oh this is a good reason for me to go
grab the ar glasses that's why they just
sit on the shelf like
it has to be part of your day-to-day
experience and it has to augment your
life in a way
that makes it worthwhile but you have
the chicken and egg problems so
i think you know some of the things that
we're working on at walmart
you know you need to be able to map the
physical environment for ar to be really
successful
and so starting out with use cases like
where we can map out the physical store
and you come into the store and you just
borrow the glasses for the time you're
there
and you get to walk through the store
and you get to see you know
information stuff and show up in a
different language somebody talking to
you
picking up a product asking information
you know about
the contents i'm sorry to interrupt
because i'm i'm leaving so thank you
thank you very much for watching i'm
going to let you go
but real quick a lot of comments around
ikea
and ar i'm i'm not like how far along
are they
from youtube yeah yeah wayfair
uh do a fantastic job of that you
basically scan the scanning
to mark's point that scanning took a
while before a couple of years ago love
you guys
it would take you a while to scan your
room now you just hold it up
it finds that flat surface and you see
it but to your point mark i think that
there are different levels of ar right
there's that basic level of ar that i'm
talking about
whereby i want to go buy something
online and eventually get to clothing
and whatnot but
i want to buy a piece of furniture for
my house and i can actually see how it
fits
um and fit is an issue it's not even fit
it's more like just decor
really um but to your point can go
requires
more equipment yeah that's a niche use
case and i think
you know we we've kind of filled in some
of those niches for it to go
mainstream you know i think it needs to
be glasses eyewear
the eyewear needs to look like you know
regular glasses which they're starting
to
and then there just needs to be more
reasons to wear them like really
like uh reasons that make your life
easier otherwise people
aren't going to bother absolutely mark
in
the few minutes we have left i want to
go back to entrepreneurship for a moment
if it's okay yeah all right one of the
things that
that you mentioned that i've heard you
say that that really resonated with me
and i think it'll resonate with the
audience as well
is is you've talked about the fact that
a lot of people think that to be an
entrepreneur you have to have a
completely new idea
but what you did effectively incredibly
effectively and successfully
was put a twist on somebody that was
there and execute
far better than others can you talk to
us a little bit
the twist part i understand there's an
improvement and whatnot but talk to us
about the execution part what tips do
you have for those
people that see something they want to
change it
what are those tips for better execution
yeah first off you're absolutely right i
think
any any idea can work as a business with
a with a few
small modifications maybe not exactly as
you have envisioned
it but but in any sector in any space
you can make a business
a business work um i think you know i
talk about
vcp vision capital people um
that's what it's that's what it's all
about when i'm starting business those
are the three things i've got you know
all my focus on um make sure that you've
got a clear vision for what you want to
become in the future
and again it could be something that
already exists but just you think it
could be done better or you're not sure
why is this have to be a pain point this
is a big market
this company's doing really well but
they could do it better and so
don't be shy about going into a market
with already uh
you know a big competitor if you think
that there's an opportunity to do it
better
and then you have to line up the capital
and the people and
and then let it be an execution game so
you got to bring the absolute best
people on board
and you got to make sure you don't under
capitalize you have enough capital to
bring the best people in
and if you can do that um i think you
can make anything work
in a vision for a moment so for the
companies that you started
presumably you or a small group of
people had the initial vision for
something
when you build when you cast the
leadership team and you bring them in
how much of that vision and and are you
driving or do you allow them to
influence as well
i think you you have to allow them
influence it so they feel a part of it
um but but you can't it's really just
tweaking the
the big vision you have to have
and be really clear when you're bringing
people on board sharing it
and hiring people that buy into that
vision and they're like yeah that sounds
great i
i believe that too i've been thinking
about that okay yeah great you know
and then you can tweak it and i would
say the tweaking is more the strategy
like what is the how do you get there
what's the sequencing of the moves
but the the big vision you want to find
people that
that buy into that when you bring them
on board you really don't want that to
to change and then once you're having
these discussions and there are
points of impasse that you get to and
certain key decisions
is it that vision that you all go back
and look at and say okay are we
now still delivering this vision or
which decision will get us there
yeah absolutely i spent uh an incredible
amount of time on both the mission
the vision and then the the strategy but
like in broad strokes to strategy not
like you know
strategic objectives but broad like how
are you going to get there it's 10 years
out this big vision
what are the broad strokes to to see
that
that you need to do to make that vision
happen and then mission is also
important too just knowing
why you exist um what's the the sort of
inspirational reason for being and uh
it's important to know that too so you
have the the vision what you want to
become
and the mission kind of why you exist
and and
couple that also with a strong set of
core values so that you can build
a really strong foundation for the
culture bring in great people
and execute it i think a lot of people
miss that part around
culture and building that foundation and
getting the org structure right too
so that you could you can move with
speed
yeah absolutely i think the the thing
again that really resonated with me was
your focus on execution and the fact
that
it doesn't have to be something
incredibly novel what you're doing to
your point any idea will work
you just have to do it better um
speaking about
entrepreneurship again i love your
serious startup stand-up focused on
empowering female entrepreneurs
why did it start why did it start you
said
yes why did it start yeah so you know i
was a mentor
to a lot of entrepreneurs that come for
advice on on raising money
and just general you know startup advice
and i found it really interesting
that uh you know uh women had a really
hard time raising money
and and harder time than men for what i
thought were the same or better business
plans in many cases i was just baffled
by it
and i think this was just a real problem
in in in the market
and i wanted to just sort of like i
don't help
and do my part a little bit to see if i
can help close the gap
uh so i started this sort of stand up
and you know i find uh you know
female entrepreneurs typically you know
with a focus on minority
female entrepreneurs that that are early
stage that don't have a lot of
experience in entrepreneurship
and just help them you know formulate
their their pitch deck
um and and work through some of the
early you know
challenges yeah yeah what kind of um
how do you inject your expertise and
knowledge to help them
succeed without taking over too much and
at the same time what kind of trends are
you seeing out of that group
yeah i think i mean it's worked pretty
well i mean i think a lot of
entrepreneurs share
the same challenges you know they they
have an idea
they have a pitch um and they start and
talk to a few investors before it's
really polished
the investors say no and they tell them
and give them advice and things and the
entrepreneur goes back and
changes their their their idea and
it's unbelievable how often that happens
because you know you just say oh well
the investor doesn't want to invest they
said do this
maybe i should do that and then they
would invest but the fact is
um you know any even a successful
startup will get a lot more no's than
yeses especially first-time entrepreneur
it's really really hard to get somebody
to to invest
my advice would be stick to your vision
um and just keep honing the the the
pitch
um with each person you talk to
just take those learnings and then hone
it but don't don't change your idea
don't change the vision
just just hone the pitch that's that's
one big thing that i found another thing
is a lot of times people a little bit
shy about
talking about their big vision and think
they need to focus on
all the things that they're doing today
and they get caught up
sharing so much about what they're doing
today that the business seems small
and then venture capitals they need to
see 1020x
multi hundred million dollar billion
dollar exit and you might be thinking
yeah i would love that
but i can't start talking about that now
when i just started i have two
two employees and i'm in the weeds here
well yes you can
i think i would start off by sharing the
big vision
if everything would go exactly they
wanted over the next 10 years
what do you want to become why and then
and then what is the strategy for
getting there
and then walk them backwards to today
and say okay that's the big vision
that's the plan
this is how we're starting we're
starting here and that could be really
really small but at least now they have
context
for you know you have this big vision
and yeah of course you gotta start
somewhere
some people don't don't spend enough
time on setting the framework and the
stage for how
how uh you know ambitious goals they
have
i would recommend they do that that's
wonderful thank you
uh mark it's been an absolute pleasure
for you um so having followed your
career for
for years um and witnessed kind of
from again from a consumer standpoint
all the success you've had
i'm sure there are a lot of amazing
stories of amazing times what i'd like
to understand
out of all of your career uh experiences
what six month period was the most
energizing for you and why
the most energizing yeah most
entertaining fun you had what was a
six month period i think it had to be
the
you know the start of diapers.com that
had to be the most fun i mean
it was like me and vinnie were the
co-founders of that and we literally did
everything from you know doing the
accounting the merchandising
the web design picking up customer calls
buying the diapers at costco i mean
the it was just all in non-stop
24 7. and it was just fun to see it go
from nothing to something
um so such a short period of time so
yeah that'd be it
that's amazing mark thanks again for
your time thank you
back on as well all right take care